it's probably Quinn I've been hearing
about this animated series for a while
and it supposed to be hilarious very
funny you know a bit edgy but people say
it's great it's got really good buzz on
it I didn't get this part this sounds
like a dream thing for you it is a dream
thing for me it came because I worked on
another DC project called powerless
which was about a group of people who
didn't have superpowers in the superhero
Society and him they found out hey
nobody wants to watch that yeah no they
won't that's it that's a terrible hey
I've got an idea it's a world of
superheroes but we focus on the four
people that don't have power yeah yeah I
mean I was thank you for the money but
yeah bad idea so then they're like you
know what people like super here so they
made the Harley Quinn show and they
asked me to play King shark who was like
half-man half-shark very intelligent but
also a bloodthirsty murderer and I was
like that's right up my alley it's
interesting because the character talks
like you and it well first of all we
have a picture of the character who
looks incredibly intimidating but also
sweet inside right yeah very cute very
nice hoodie he would definitely wear
this outfit he's a great guy just don't
get in his way right is that you do you
have a lot of anger inside yeah what
about I mean so it does it come out you
lose it on people because around you on
tour and you were the Comus guy you know
very calm very sweet very nice anybody I
just can't imagine you getting mad well
you don't want I got into office by a
pot store one say you know you got into
a fistfight at a pot store yeah yeah
about what
well the guy was being racist towards
the clerk and then you know it wasn't he
he wasn't another black guy was the
Asian guy so I at first I was like I
don't even have a horse in this race wow
this person's being racist but not
towards my race so I should probably sit
I should but I learned about myself I
just don't like racism and so then oh
what
[Applause]
the rest of you are too late hey that
ribbing against racism thing went over
well if he mentions it again let's get
on board so wait so he was being racist
towards someone who and and you got mad
I got mad at him because I was just like
hey the guy already told you get out of
the store I don't know why getting all
races and ignorant it's not gonna solve
anything and so then I was like if you
want to fight somebody fight me win so
then he punch me in the face
and I was like oh I thought you were
going back - so what did you do then you
punched him no but you said you got into
a fistfight and for you that means I got
punched in the face and then it was over
it means I got punched in the face twice
and then he ran away because he realized
I wasn't going that I was crazy and I
was mad I got in one fist fight in my
life and it was the same thing someone
who I didn't know I was even in a fight
with got mad hit me like twice in the
face really hard and then I broke my
nose got broken so I got all bandaged
nothing happened to them and I would
walk around people go they would see my
black eyes and my nose and they'd be
like haha I bet the other guy doesn't
look together the other guy looks
amazing my guy was real good if I and he
he had done it a few times so you what
did you just buy some pot then and leave
they gave me some free boy
in the facebook pod what a happy ending
to this story all right well I want to
make sure I mentioned this I'm very
excited and this out you know maybe I'll
get invited to this wedding you know
yeah I consider us good friends even
though you know you seem non-committal
about it I'm so judging you really no I
think I'll judge you by the gift that
you bring to the way you don't bring the
gate I don't ever bring the gift to the
wedding you don't oh no I have the
dealer Drive it later on don't you do
that Andy I send the gift after the
wedding
yeah it's cash you know the Italian
mafia wedding what are you doing I got a
lot of shady friends
congratulations where's my money
[Laughter]